oui vous y avoir qu'une seule chose non
invasif et oye como
oreilles mais ouais dans les épaules
alors je ne sais pas le pointu continue
les ans il a des jambes magnifiques à
jouer ça c'est là des gens mariés vous
pouvez montrer aux gens à dire arrête le
ballon non mais c'est rien
catherine va dans ce que valent ces
formidables c'est un bon soldat
non non si tu veux pas tu le fais pas tu
relève juste le bac pompanon mais nous
avons envie de montrer mes jambes
mais n'arriva pas montré par en bas
mentalement qu'est-ce qui fait se
déshabille
[Applaudissements]
34 cents badawi s'emmerde pas attendre
t'emmerde pas il ya des enfants qui
rentrent de l'école c'est pas pour ça et
on s'est dit on lui dit dessapt os des
salles une série comme ça mais ça
l'amour et c'est un très grand joueur
mais en amour